على هذا الطريق البعيد ينتظر احد المسلحين
الاوامر بالتحرك وفي مكان ما بعيدا عن
الانظار يعقد اتفاق لتبادل
الاسرى نحن الان بانتظار المركبه الاولى
التي نعتقد انها تحمل اربع سجناء من
المسلمين السنه وهذا يعتبر الجزء الاول من
عمليه
التبادل الشاحنه تحمل اسرى من السنه
والرجل الذي يق هو شيخ شيعي عندي شغل
وبينما يتهم الثوار وغالبيتهم من السنه
الاقليه الشيعيه بالتعاطف مع النظام
السوري يخشى البعض ان تنجر البلاد نحو
العنف الطائفي بنا انه ما يعني هي شغله
الطائفيه سني وعلويه وشيعه ما عننا
هحكي مثل ما قال لك زميلنا
المجاهد هي نظام بدعنا
اياها واخيرا وصلت القافله وسط ترحيب كبير
من الطرفين
السكان دعوا الشيخ الشيعي للبقاء لتناول
عشاء الا انه من الواضح انه يريد المغادره
ولكنه يريد محاوره المسلحين السنه عننا
بنات عن عن بنا ما حدنا غير
الله
واح مشان ايش مشان ايش ياين بناتنا
عن عن
ح
ومن ثم غادر الشيخ بصحبه السجناء الشيعه
واحدهم يبدو عليه اثار
التعذيب
حت جماعه
مسلحين مع الكثير من العناق والقبلات يبدو
ان عمليه التبادل قد
انجزت وبهذا الانجاز الدبلوماسي يبدو ان
السوريون نجحوا في تفادي شبح الحرب
الطائفيه الى حد
ما m